IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: Hi, everyone.
I'm Ibrahim Ulukaya from
YouTube API Developer
Relations Team, and today we
will talk about the Live
Streaming API, and we will
showcase the great
integration.
It's called RadioLine.
Actually, they were one of the
first integrators of the
YouTube Live Streaming API.
And today, we will showcase
API with the guys--
the folks from RadioLine
themselves.
The CEO of RadioLine,
Thomas Serval, will
be joining me today.
And Samuel Landau is the
CTO of RadioLine.
And we'll talk about
RadioLine.
Hey, Thomas, how are you?
THOMAS SERVAL: I'm
fine, thank you.
Hello, Ibrahim.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: Thanks
so much for
joining me here today.
Maybe let's talk about
what is RadioLine?
What's the product itself?
THOMAS SERVAL: So RadioLine
has one goal.
It's to make your radio
universally
available across the world.
And the first thing we wanted
to do is to make sure we are
the number one video site
and one of the best
websites in the world.
So we wanted to be present on
YouTube as a first move and as
a first product for
the company.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: And how did
you come up with the idea?
Right now, we know that
RadioLine line is creating
this [INAUDIBLE] experience
on YouTube.
How does the idea came from?
THOMAS SERVAL: Well, actually,
I used to be a YouTuber
before, and one of the things
that I had to do
is to travel a lot.
And I'm also a big radio fan.
So when I wanted to listen to
my favorite radio, I was
watching a lot of YouTube
channels, but I had to switch
to another website.
And also, I was doing other
things while working, and I
wanted to listen to
my favorite radio.
So I said this is stupid.
Why don't we use YouTube,
which has a great search
engine, to find out what is
going on live on radio and
make them available
by live streaming?
So I started discussing
with you guys, and you
came up with the API.
And we said, OK, now it's
becoming possible.
So that's how we end up having
this idea of making radios
available on YouTube.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: That's great.
Can you just show us a bit of
the demo itself, the website
and the actual YouTube
channel?
THOMAS SERVAL: Yeah, so
with great pleasure.
It's a big task, so I
just want to make
sure that we are not--
we are just available
right now in France.
And let me share my screen
and walk you through the
experience we envision.
So you have to speak a little
bit of French, but I'm going
to do the real-time
translation.
This is our website right
now for French radio.
It's called
youtube.com/radiolinefr, and
there's a little video that
explains how it works.
I don't know if you can
hear the sound.
But this is what you can do,
is you can listen to any of
your favorite radio by searching
it inside the
YouTube search engine.
So, for instance, one of my
favorite radio could be
RTL or Europe 1.
And we have categorized
all the radios.
So, for instance, I'm looking
for [INAUDIBLE] containing
food, or I'm looking
for talk radio, or
I'm looking for live.
So I will choose Europe 1, which
is a news radio, and
live you can listen to what's
going on on Europe 1.
And you have next to the title
of the radio the metadata, so
what's actually on air.
And that's actually not so easy,
so in real time, we are
changing the description of
the video so people know
what's being aired
at every moment.
And if you like this radio, then
on the right side, you
have suggestion of other radio
or other programs that are
live at the same time
that you might be
interested in listening.
So I like news.
Maybe I want to listen to
business news, so I will click
on the right side, and
I will switch to the
news in real time.
And you see we have the programs
that is on the bottom
left side with the name
and the schedule.
So It gives a lot of information
to the user so
they can navigate between their
favorite radio programs.
So right now, this is available
for 50 French
radios, but we are going to
extend it to all news, talk,
and sports radio across the
world in the coming months.
I think that's about it at the
moment, but we are thinking
about adding new features.
And as soon as the new features
are implemented also
in the Live API, we
can enhance the
experience on the radio.
So we have a lot of feedback
from earlier beta testers
about having more information
being shown on the screen, and
it will automatically show more
information about the
radio and the programming
live.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: That's
great, actually.
Maybe actually we can see
a little bit from my own
computer and hear the audio and
see one of the channels?
So let's go to Europe 1.
THOMAS SERVAL: I'll let you
hear one of the channels.
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: Thomas, explain
it to the users--
THOMAS SERVAL: That's a French
weather forecast.
They tell you that there is
a little heat wave around
France, so I hope
you want visit
this part of the country.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: So yeah,
that like one of the
streams over there.
Yeah, maybe it's a good time
to actually go in depth a
little bit about the
API integrations.
Since you're already doing the
live streaming using the Live
Stream platform for this, also
you are one of the first
integrators of the API, maybe
at this time somehow the CTO
of RadioLine can join me and can
help explain about how the
integration went so far
and what are the other
expectations on the
API itself.
SAMUEL LANDAU: Hi.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: So how was
your app implemented?
Can you talk a little bit?
SAMUEL LANDAU: So I sent
you a diagram.
Maybe you can show it?
So basically, we have
implemented connectors from
our RadioLine service that use
the radio audio streams to
encode the video stream
that we send to
YouTube Live Stream.
And on the other hand, we have
made an automaton that
regularly updates the
metadata for the
YouTube live broadcast.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: So actually,
as well as your Live
Streaming, too, you are also
updating the your metadata all
the time with your app, right?
SAMUEL LANDAU: Yes.
So the RadioLine service
platform is providing this
metadata, and so we just had
to make a program which is
both a client from RadioLine and
a client to YouTube Live
APIs, and also encode this video
with information and
creating metadata and the
audio radio stream.
Actually, we had to do
a quick [INAUDIBLE]
implementation, so we first
made a PHP implementation.
So actually, that's
a web service.
And our next implementation
will be a [INAUDIBLE]
server with some back office
functionalities I did.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: Was there
anything surprising while you
were using the API itself?
Because actually you started
really early testing the API,
even before the other uses.
SAMUEL LANDAU: Yes.
We had a lot of surprises.
But I was surprised by the
swiftness of API updates on
YouTube behalf when they were
requesting some new parameters
or functionality.
And like the day after or two
days after, it was available,
so I was impressed.
Also, what surprised us a lot
was the fast indexing of the
live broadcast.
Actually, the live broadcasts
have this 24-hour limitation,
so we have to recreate
them every day since
our radios are 24/7.
So every day, we recreate the
live broadcasts, and we did
not expect for these live
broadcasts to be indexed so
quickly in the YouTube engine.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: I see.
And for like a counterintuitive
thing, you
actually mentioned about the
24-hour limitation, right?
You actually had to create
your own, I think,
refresher for that?
SAMUEL LANDAU: Yes.
We had to make a kind of back
office that permits this live
broadcast recreation to overcome
the limitation.
While we understand that most
live events are short-lived,
but for our needs, our specific
needs as a RadioLine
service, we need it 24/7.
Radios do not stop streaming.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: I think you
also ask it as a feature, and
hopefully, we may get to that.
Have you actually tried the
other APIs, like data API?
And have you ever used
the other APIs on
top of the Live Streaming?
SAMUEL LANDAU: Yes, actually.
Thomas mentioned the channel
and the playlist.
We automated their management,
so we are using that API
literally, actually.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: And can you
give us a little bit more on
the feedback side or the other
features you want to implement
and you want to see in the Live
Streaming API, or could
be the data API or other
APIs as well?
SAMUEL LANDAU: We plan on
adding some back office
functionality so that we can
offer a service to radios in
the streams.
So we will need richer
live queue codes.
Today it's a bit limited.
Also, for live radios, the
description includes the
program of the radio, so we will
very much like to have a
description that updates
in the user's screen.
Today they are static.
Also, we think it would be nice
to have annotations like
in the YouTube service.
We understand that for live
event, it has many new
constraints.
But we think it will
be very nice.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: OK, great.
Maybe this time I can go back to
my own screen and a little
bit summarize actually what they
were doing at RadioLine.
As you know, YouTube has a Live
Streaming platform, and
we also made available
the API itself.
So by using the Live Streaming
platform, they're actually
streaming all these videos they
are sending to YouTube,
and actually those videos are
available as live streaming.
And at the same time, what they
did is they actually used
the API to create
those events.
Other than creating them again
and again, they actually use
an automation tool which they
actually create all
this using the API.
They set the streams.
They were able to update all the
metadata on top of them,
and they use it as creating
the new events, or rather,
refreshing the events,
and they use the
API from that side.
And I guess it was like the most
of the talk, and maybe I
can just show a few other radios
that are available from
the RadioLine.
As you guys see, they actually
have not only one stream, they
actually have a few streams
going on at the same time.
All the radios are available
through the channel, which
they created multiple
events in there on
their own YouTube channel.
And saying that, I guess that
was most of the RadioLine and
how they use the Live
Streaming API.
Thanks so much for joining
me, guys, today.
It was really nice to hear you
guys, and I know it was quite
also challenging a lot of you
guys trying to be a tester,
development, and went so far to
create an amazing platform
on top of the YouTube
Live Streaming.
THOMAS SERVAL: Thank
you very much--
SAMUEL LANDAU: Thank you.
THOMAS SERVAL: --for your app.
Thank you.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: Thanks a lot.
And before finishing, as you
guys know, we are always
hiring almost everywhere around
the world for the
Developer Relations Team.
Just go to
developer.google.com/jobs, and
you will see all of the
open positions.
Thanks a lot for joining
me, guys.
Ibrahim Ulukaya from
New York, thanks.